we've talked on the show before about
the federal government having sued the
Trump Organization back in 1973 for race
discrimination and I've also talked
about it being a really bad idea for
Donald Trump to go to war with the
intelligence community when it's
abundantly clear that they have a ton of
damaging material about Donald Trump as
we are learning almost every day the
Justice Department accused the company
that was run by Donald Trump and his
father Fred Trump of violating the Fair
Housing Act by refusing to rent
apartments to black and Puerto Rican
people here's the lawsuit on screen for
people who were watching with us and the
FBI lo and behold what coincidental
timing has now released almost 400 pages
of records from that investigation and
the details while not surprising because
we sort of had a sense of what this
lawsuit was about are hugely disturbing
the the documents reveal that black
people were often told that no
apartments were available when they
would call looking for apartments or
show up looking for apartments at the
exact same time white people would call
or show up looking for apartments and
all of a sudden there were plenty of
apartments available the black people
who were accepted into potentially
acquiring apartments from the Trump
Organization were being charged
significantly more money than were white
people and the FBI file which again is
stunning it includes dozens of
interviews with tenants and management
and employees there's a doorman at a
Trump building in Brooklyn who was
quoted as saying a supervisor told me
that if a black person came to 2650
Ocean Parkway and inquired about an
apartment for rent and he was not there
at the time that I should tell the
person who was inquiring about renting
an apartment that rent was twice as much
as it really was in order that he could
not afford the apartment then there's
another Trump employee who said Fred
Trump came to me and said he wanted to
get rid of black people from the
building by telling them that cheap
housing was available elsewhere for only
a $500 down payment which Fred Trump
would personally be willing to
a to prevent black people from renting
at his apartment of course in total and
normal and predictable Trump style the
Trump Organization responded to the
federal lawsuit with their own hundred
million dollar lawsuit against the
government for defamation that was
obviously dismissed in court the lawsuit
against the Trump's was settled with a
consent decree which made it so that the
Trump Organization didn't have to admit
fault pretty common thing in a lot of
these lawsuits that takes place but they
were required to put in a bunch of
safeguards to prevent further racial
discrimination now this came up during
one of Donald Trump's debates with
Hillary Clinton in 2016 and Trump
defended himself not by denying he
didn't say we didn't racially
discriminate what he said instead was he
bragged that he was able to solve the
lawsuit without having to admit fault
I'll remind you just a few seconds from
that debate with Hillary Clinton well he
doesn't now as far as the lawsuit yes
when I was very young I wanted to my
father's company had a real estate
company in Brooklyn and Queens and we
along with many many other companies
throughout the country as a federal
lawsuit were sued we settled the suit
with zero with no admission of guilt it
was very easy so clearly if your Trump
you should not be messing with our
intelligence agencies it's abundantly
clear they have a lot on you if only
James Comey and the FBI when they were
doing letters and press conferences
about Hillary Clinton's email scandal
had mentioned oh by the way we're also
investigating Donald Trump or for a
whole bunch of stuff including ties to
Russia alas that did not happen and alas
Donald Trump won by 77,000 votes in
three traditional swing states discuss
this with us on reddit david pakman.com
slash re d di t andrew torres from the
opening arguments podcast joins me next
Gamefly is sort of like netflix for
video games they have over 8,000 new and
classic games for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4
ps3 Wii and a bunch of other platforms
and you can play as many games as you
for one monthly fee and if you find some
games you want to keep you can buy them
for a low used price there's never any
due dates or late fees and our audience
can get a free 30-day trial at Gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s the games are
shipped directly to you with return
envelopes included there's no contracts
and you can rent games through the
mobile app get the free 30-day trial for
the David Pakman show audience and
support our show by going to Gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s